now the head of the Wagner group has
released his first statement since the
group's armed Mutiny on June 24th in an
11-minute audio recording that was just
released fergogen explained that Wagner
was bound to cease to exist on July 1st
and he says that the goal of the March
was to prevent the eradication of Wagner
and to quote ensure that those who made
a huge amount of mistakes during these
special military operation be held
responsible let's go to Yulia shop of
Oliver in Moscow Julia bring us up to
speed 11 minutes there was time for
Evgeni pragosian to say a lot in that
audio recording
exactly I just have to take my time to
listen at all well the latest reports
are saying that frigursion actually has
been seen in Minsk Belarus and basically
what he is saying is that the ministry
of Defense wanted to disband the Wagner
group but their purpose was not to
capture the power in Russia so basically
they're a goal their purpose of their
campaign of their March was to prevent
the destruction disbandment of the
Wagner group and that those
individuals who actually wanted to to do
that they will be held accountable and
obviously he continues blaming the
Russian Ministry of defense for all the
mistakes they uh they committed and
basically what we hear and see is
developing very quick clear because
earlier on we were talking about
business and as usual and we're talking
about the Russian authorities who are
getting back to business on Monday and
Vladimir Putin was speaking on the phone
with his Iranian counterpart with the
Iranian president and Emir of Qatar and
both leaders expressed their support to
Russia and it's a leadership condemning
the Mutiny conducted by the avagna chief
and Putin and his Iranian counterpart
also discussed issues like ensuring
stability in the trans caucuses region
and the Assyrian settlement while
foreign minister Sergey lavrov gave his
assessment on the Rebellion calling it
unsuccessful and saying that the Russian
special services are now investigating
whether the Western intelligence
Services were involved in the events on
Saturday all right this audio statement
by burgosian is yet another remarkable
development in everything that's been
happening really since Friday evening
Julia what are ordinary Russians saying
about this are they talking about it and
if so what are they saying about this
well actually they are talking uh
ordinary Russians are also involved in
their everyday activities many were
following the recent developments and
got quite concerned to be honest but if
you delve into the Russian social media
sources and telegram channels here an
interesting piece of news comes into
Forefront it's been um it's been a
basically Mr Mr shoigu's first public
appearance since evgeny preggers march
on a number of Russian cities a few days
ago the media shows shoigu remaining in
his post and doing his business on the
front line in the lugansk region and
it's quite significant significant
because
um well recently there were many
speculations that Ashok could be
replaced there are many opponents of him
and many have admitted numerous mistakes
in the Army's management and severely
criticized its leadership but Russia's
president has been reluctant to change
the Minister of Defense in order to not
to admit all those mistakes and now
after the Rebellion things have changed
according to official reports during the
Wagner March at least two regular uh
well at least two army helicopters and
the plane were shot down by Wagner and
obviously a number of Pilots died so now
many ask who will be responsible for the
loss of all those people and Equipment
well and uh well again had become a
former former pretext now to to make a
big decision now and probably change the
minister of defense and just a short
while ago at least four Pro World
telegram Channels with more than 7
million subscribers published reports
that the governor of the Tula region
Alexei Duman could replace Sergey shoigu
as a defense minister shortly once again
it's not official information but it's
spreading very quickly here Duman is the
former head of Putin's security and for
a short time he was deputy minister of
defense and then became the governor of
the Tula region and during the
preggersian Rebellion there was
information that Alexei German
participated in negotiations with the
head of the Wagner group but the two
original authorities denied that so
experts say any change in the leadership
of the Russian Ministry of Defense would
mean a significant victory for preggers
who launched his Rebellion blaming
shoigu and the head of the Russian
general staff gerasima for the deaths of
tens of thousands of Russian soldiers in
Ukraine so we're monitoring all the
developments here and of course we are
about to listen to the whole that's a
longer very longer audio by Mr pregosia
absolutely you your shop of olive oil
thank you very much for your reporting
there from Moscow now Russian State
media say that the head of the Wagner
mercenary group progosian is still under
criminal investigation however the
foreign minister says that his
rebellious mercenary group will still
remain active in countries including
Mali and the Central African Republic
Rory challenge reports
crisis what crisis after the drama and
Chaos of the weekend this is Russia's
political and Military leadership trying
to show that everything is fine Vladimir
Putin speaking to an industrial forum
and the first footage of the defense
minister released since Wagner boss
yevgeni pregosian called for his sacking
and launched a short-lived Mutiny
briefly advancing on Moscow
though we don't know when it was filmed
the message is clear it's the Kremlin
saying no mercenary leader can force
Vladimir Putin to do anything
at a government meeting prime minister
mashushtin urged Russians to unify
we need to act together as one team and
maintain the unity of all our forces
rallying around the president we need to
take calculated unified decisions to
effectively achieve goals set by the
leader of the state but for observers in
the west the events are signs that
Russia's war in Ukraine has exposed deep
Fishers in the Russian president's hold
on power the monster that Putin created
with the banner the monster is biting
him now the monster is acting against
his creator the political system is in
showing the facilities
and the military power is cracking so
this is an important consequence of the
war in Japan
China is concerned by the possibility of
a chaotic State collapse in its
strategic partner Russia but the foreign
Ministry is saying little Beyond General
words of support
the incident of Wagner group you
mentioned is Russia's internal Affair as
Russia's friendly neighbor and
comprehensive strategic partner of
coordination for the new era China
supports Russia maintaining National
stability in achieving development and
prosperity
evgeny pregosian is supposedly headed
for Belarus in the deal brokered by
Belarusian President Alexander
lukashenko brigosian was initially
understood to have had Mutiny charges
against him in Russia dropped but some
Russian media are reporting the Wagner
boss remains under investigation Rory
challenge Al Jazeera
foreign Ministers of the European Union
have been discussing the situation in
Russia and everything that transpired
Dominic Kane is live for us in Berlin
Dominic how are European powers I should
men to mention of course the NATO
Secretary General has also been talking
about this how are they all actually
handling this I mean other than saying
the obvious that there are cracks in the
Russian armor
well we've been hearing from Luxembourg
today chapter and verse from different
foreign ministers about how they see the
situation from a general perspective
vis-a-vis Ukraine and then opining some
of them at least publicly about what
they think has happened in Russia over
the last few days and so annelina
belbach the German foreign minister
pretty clear saying that she believes
that this shows that there are massive
cracks in Russian propaganda and let's
be clear she has been condemnatory of
almost everything that Russia has done
since the start of what the Russians
call their special military operation
where everybody else calls the war in
Ukraine and the other thing to point out
is that there has been some material
assistance that the EU is providing
today being announced that a further a
the ceiling on money that can be
provided to Ukraine has been increased
by a third up to more than 12 billion
euros available to the Ukrainian
government from the EU perspective
that's the sort of thing that's being
talked about today at least publicly
all right Dominic Kane reporting from
Berlin thank you very much Dominic now
as we mentioned earlier we are getting
the first indication from the Russian
foreign minister that Wagner is here to
stay in Mali and in the Central African
Republic where they've been active let's
talk to Nicholas hack in Senegal's
capital Dakar Nick who are those
comments by Sergey lavrov aimed at who
is he trying to reassure when he says
Wagner will continue what it's doing in
Mali and car
close here
seriously he's trying to reassure those
governments that have contracts with the
Wagner group notably Molly the Central
African Republic there's also Mozambique
Libya Sudan there's dozens of them that
have uh military contracts and deals
with the Wagner group but he's also
trying to reassure the 3 000 Russian
citizens and Fighters that work for the
Wagner group that are on the ground and
that haven't heard up until now from
their leader pregogin so those are the
two people those are the two groups of
people but also the leader of the Wagner
group himself because in this public
statement he's also trying to reassure
that bagner's interest
in Africa which is quite important will
continue to go on and will continue to
benefit the group it still is a
for-profit organization so the fighters
the Prego Jin himself as well as the
African governments that rely on the
Wagner group for their security those
are the people that uh the the this
comment is addressed to me yeah how
Reliant are they Nick on Wagner these
countries
well if you talk about Central African
Republic their Reliance is extremely
heavy on the Wagner group essentially
the Wagner Fighters are not there just
to fight off armed groups that are
active there are about 14 armed groups
active in the Central African Republic
but they also provide private security
to president Twitter himself uh in Mali
same thing the the Wagner Fighters are
on the front line in mukti finding off
armed groups linked to Al-Qaeda and and
the in the local affiliate to isil and
what's interesting the timing of lavros
comment is quite interesting because in
Mali there is the biggest and most
expensive U.N operation uh minut and the
Malian Junta has called on that
peacekeeping operation to end much of
that uh is down to the fact that they
can they say rely on their Russian
partnership to go on but what was
interesting to see during the last few
days on Saturday at the beginning of the
Rebellion preguzin uh in his address in
the telegram mentioned Africa okay he
said I quote we were told that we were
needed in Africa and he's referring to
the Kremlin but we were abandoned and
all the money and support that was
supposed to give in to us was stolen he
felt that he was at it alone but what's
clear here is that Wagner needs the
support of Russia but the Kremlin needs
Wagner in order to continue to exert its
influence on the numerous countries in
the region
Nicholas hack reporting from Dakar
Senegal thank you very much now the
office of Belarusian president
of the Belarusian President says it is
unsure if uh evgeny pagosian is in
Belarus we'll see whether that actually
changes in light of the latest
statements uh by evgeny pragosian that
were just released
um now we're going to be able to
let's listen I'm being told that we now
are able to bring you audio from the
Wagner's Chief Evgeni pagosian listen to
this
result
as a result of intrigue Wagner was bound
to cease to exist on July the 1st the
decision was made at the worst possible
moment despite us showing no aggression
we were hit by a rocket strike and then
by helicopters around 30 Fighters were
killed some were wounded this triggered
the decision to move out immediately
the goal of the March was to prevent the
eradication of Wagner ensuring those who
made a huge amount of mistakes during
the special military operation because
of their incompetence be held
accountable
before I go to our next guest I want to
bring you up to speed on the sequence of
events how things unfolded since Friday
well on Friday pregosian blamed defense
minister shoigu for attacking Wagner
camps and he started with what he he
undertook what he called a March for
justice with 25 000 Fighters overnight
his troops marched into Russia's rostov
undone then to Varnish pragosian says
Russian troops let them through without
a fight then Vladimir Putin addresses
the nation and calls those taking part
in Mutiny traitors and threatens to
punish them just hours later pregosian
turns his Fighters around saying that he
wants to avoid spilling Russian blood
the Kremlin says fragosian will go to
Belarus while his Fighters will go back
to Ukraine
Victor olivich joins us now from Moscow
he's a political analyst and the lead
expert at the think tank the center for
actual politics Victor we laid out the
timeline there now we're in Uncharted
Territory we just got the audio from
pregosian I don't know how much of it
you were able to listen to what do you
make of it
foreign
well it's definitely a very dangerous
situation
where
units under different command structures
were involved in fighting as you
mentioned there was an airplane shut
down a military plane there were several
helicopters shut down there were armed
the Russian army conducted an airstrike
on a Russian Highway while the Wagner a
Wagner military column was passing
these are tragic and very concerning
events and even though
at this point the situation has this
temporarily has been resolved
it's not completely
clear if this is the end of this crisis
or if this or similar crisis May spill
over in the coming months
and it's important to note that it's a
dangerous it's a possibly dangerous
situation not just for Russia
it's also a potentially dangerous
situation for the West it's a
potentially dangerous situation for
other for Russia's other neighbors
in the last since the beginning of the
20th century
Russia has undergone violent change
several times in 1917 two revolutions
that brought down the Russian Empire and
a civil war issued for several years but
at that time nuclear weapons did not
exist obviously Russia was not a nuclear
power and could not present a challenge
like that to to its neighbors or to
other States in 1991
the Soviet Union collapsed and it was
the primary nuclear power in the world
but the Soviet collapse the Soviet
Union's collapse was controlled and it
happened in dialogue with the West in
fact the United States
sponsored the removal of nuclear weapons
from Ukraine from Belarus and from
Kazakhstan to Russia effectively to
ensure their safety and a single command
and control structure over them
but at this point
we are seeing that the very events that
may be making some in the west happy
were glad
these very events may also be presenting
a grave danger for the West
so it's a question
and it's an important question to raise
is pushing Russia too far
is isolating Russia too much is
sanctioning Russia
too heavily can can those measures bring
Russia to a such an unstable situation
that the threat that the Westwood face a
threat of an entirely different
magnitude Victor I'm going to jump
because at this point and your point is
the worst may like or dislike Victor I'd
like I'd like to jump in because there
are a few things that have just happened
very recently that we'd like to address
um
before though
you just said this raises the question
of how the West should be handling this
and do they want a Putin controlled
Russia I'm paraphrasing here do they
want to Putin control Russia or would
they risk going somewhere into the
unknown but this was an internal Feud
you bring up the West this was between
Putin and in a a relatively unsanctioned
military Chief within Russia
foreign
well we understand very well that the
situation would not have happened
if first if the special military
operation would not have been initiated
and secondly if the pressure on Russia
and internal pressure did not create
circumstances for it
you see there are almost no liberals or
pro-western elements left in the
government
there are no liberal elements left in
Russia that could take over from Putin
if something would happen to the current
powers that be
so it's important for the West
to consider the possibility that if
Western pressure
at some point destabilizes Putin's
government that any type of regime or
any type of government that comes to
replace him
or to challenge the current authorities
okay we'd be much more into Western and
maybe much more dangerous and in fact
Victor that point is well taken and and
we hear you on that but before I let you
go I actually do need you to address the
information that we just got moments ago
which is evgeny pregosian releasing his
first
uh statement for lack of a better word
audio uh since all of this transpired
and I want to bring you I don't know if
you were able to hear it so I'd like to
bring you some of the headlines from
what you've gaining pagosian said he
said all we wanted to do was to hold
accountable those who made mistakes and
the reason Wagner turned on Russia's
military leadership again I'm
paraphrasing here uh was because they
were aggressive towards us not the other
way around we did not I repeat we did
not march to overthrow the military
leadership those are the last lines that
we got from evgeny pregosian
your reaction to that
well of course uh any leader of a mutiny
or a revolution always has
justifications for their actions and of
course it's quite logical that the head
of Wagner would blame Russia's military
leadership
who he has been in conflict with for
months
for what happened but they're very
events when
when a key southern city in Russia stov
ondon has had been taken over by a
private military company when the staff
headquarters of Russia's Southern
military District the rest of London had
been taken over by the Wagner group and
when Wagner group
mercenaries and Fighters had been moving
towards Moscow City do several of
Russia's regions of course whatever that
whatever justifications are stated by
pregozian it's obvious that this created
an internally dangerous situation when
there is international fighting when
there is fighting between different
military groups within one country it's
a very dangerous situation all right
Victor olavich a political analyst and
Leadership this contains the center of
nuclear actual politics thank you so
much I'm sorry that's all the time we
have for today but thank you so much for
joining us on the program